you like when feminists go like oh and
they have like their missiles
these dick shaped things and blah blah
and i'm always thinking like well there
is physics and aerodynamics and all that
involved like if you have it shaped like
a [ __ ] i don't think it's gonna matter
i think it's gonna make it to another
country unless you frisbee it
right and even then that gap's gonna
[ __ ] be a lot of drag
um while people are talking about
eating fake [ __ ] that was before i
don't want to be responsible for that
i didn't but it was in the flowers
before we shut up
jesus [ __ ] christ is that a rolex
yes it is i finally bought one 25 years
in this business is it white gold or
stainless
i don't know what it is is it heavy no
then it's stainless
oh is that what it is thank you thank
you for taking my watch down a notch
i finally felt successful you see this
you wouldn't say that if i had brown or
black hair i guarantee you
blonde hair you'd be over here giving me
your watch
dude the me too movement has killed the
[ __ ]
my wife will not suck my dick on her
knees ever again
never will happen because your stomach
is pushing down her [ __ ] neck
her face is tilted back like this on her
four edges
it's like going down in an eight foot
pool down at the bottom and not clearing
your ears
i feel bad for your wife you know what i
because the older guys
robert kelly's and all they all call you
billy colin calls you billy
but i [ __ ] bill i'm just immediately
noticing that
i don't know about the chain if it's if
it's thick enough to be
that one that level of confidence yeah
it's more of a necklace on the chains
out
yeah he has on a fat chick ankle
bracelet around his [ __ ] neck
the greatest thing about show like say
like stand-up comedy is
it's one of the like if you go to prison
it's hard to get a job but like you can
walk out of prison and do an open mic
within the first week
and people will put you on they won't
give a [ __ ]
dude they'd be like dude you should wear
your [ __ ] orange jumpsuit
you killed somebody do you should talk
about that that'd be funny like they
wouldn't give a [ __ ]
i thought you were laughing you were
[ __ ] yawning over here no the
mushrooms are [ __ ]
killing me man i knew it wasn't just
weed i was just like there's no way i'm
taking a hit off of that there's
something going on here mushrooms baby
the shrooms i'm streaming
[Laughter]
he's shrooming and he's wearing pants
like he went riding a horse today
like side saddle or some [ __ ] i'm to
tell you how i
discovered you i you know i i do
my whole career to you yeah i was i was
struggling until
no obviously not covered not discover
you in terms of like
you did it on your own obviously but no
in terms of my
my awareness of you oh can i tell you
that story
i remember it was a big day in my career
bobby lee is finally aware of me
am i on bobby lee's radar see this is
what he's gonna do this
is when things start to happen i'm not
gonna allow this to that reversal i'm
not yeah i'm not gonna allow this to
happen very soon yeah yeah
i'm just gonna plug away you know what i
mean listen you can talk to him all you
want
i can hear it
did you guys see the picture of donald
watching his wife vote
a lot of trust in that relationship
a part of me dies every time i go into a
store and i see something they go can we
get a phone number watching somebody
give them the phone number why would you
do that
yeah i always give the same miners all
area codes
they go what's your phone number i'm
like three two three eight one eight
two one two five
we've never taken a break in the middle
of a gas station i know i had all this
momentum going on i got to start all
over again
go ahead go to the card
see this we won game one
here comes the second of the double
header if i could work with anybody dead
or alive i'd want to work with
i don't i don't want to work i want to
be home
the white ones are dollars these are 10
the green ones these are 25 the red ones
and these are 100
the black one in a progressive move the
white chip
is worth the least i fly a lot and
there's this whole new thing of
generation of people that take their
socks and their shoes off
on the plane you got to look at their
smelly feet and then they'll literally
stand up and they will walk
into a commercial airline bathroom yeah
use it and then walk and sit back down
again that's not right
yeah if i was a dictator those people
will be eliminated
you really are the whitest person i've
ever seen yes
served me well i've never worked for
anything
yeah i was born on a yacht it's just all
been downhill
i don't even mean it and i don't mean it
in a a genetic way i mean like
i do you i'm talking full-on white
privilege
[Laughter]
i was stunned when i first heard about
white privilege i had no idea what it
was
like everybody doesn't get to do this
this dude is knocking it out of the park
he's one of my favorites here is
bill burr
look at you how are you oh i know you
did the audience
applause for everybody yeah there he is
come on
keep it going it was really uh you know
you relate to adults differently
people that you knew forever and i
always hate it when somebody who didn't
have a kid goes you don't get it man
you don't get it do you have and i was
like [ __ ] you i get it it's like a
having a dog but it's more intense
i love the racist white guy thing a
bunch of racist white guys
they came out of the forest and they
were just going trump truck
trump it's like where were all these
racist white guys the last two elections
when they could have voted against the
black guy
they were fine oh i don't mind the black
guy but this white lady
we gotta stop gonna take her
[Music]
four-wheelers
every time i see you something great has
happened to you yeah this case
yeah the redstone won the world series
yeah i know i know i'm not rubbing it in
i'm not one of those guys
i don't i'm a mets fan anyway so you
could rub it in if you like
i don't i don't do that i don't go to
the stadium posing stadium where
the other teams oh you know stuff you
know running around and look at the
crowd and do that
whenever i see that i'm just like that
guy should get kicked out of him
like in a perfect world that happens
i used to wear stuff the opposing team
stuff because i'm you know i moved away
from boston but
i just got sick of it and it's not even
being in the stands it's when you go to
the bathroom
that's the worst yeah some guy knows
yeah you go out to the bathroom
they wait till you know you're doing
your thing and then they push you in
they take out their childhood on you
and you got this bullseye on your head
and it's just like why am i doing this
what am i steven seagal i'm going to
he made that movie right i think he made
a movie like that so i'm just like
i i am a very courteous fan
so if somebody said i had blood in my
stool they don't actually see
blood they see it's black right so the
higher up in your
um gi the black what sort of background
do you have
i was a nurse oh okay so yeah wow wow
because you really came off like i was
like
no this happens a lot on podcast all of
a sudden i'm listening to a comedian
like telling me
how my liver works i'm just like wait a
minute who the [ __ ] are you
okay i'm sorry all right so you're a
nurse all right look around
most people are weird-looking look at me
i'm 100 white dude i'm a weird looking
dude you know what i mean
the the best dogs are mixed dogs they're
the chillest dogs i'm telling you
you're right you're absolutely right on
that yeah
that's why that's why although that over
there in england the the royal
family that's why they're all so weird
looking they're all
banging in the same pool they're like a
bunch of dalmatians
that can talk right you're whatever
incognito you're an enigma
what because i make a pie no you know
what it is you're not a good listener
you've known me for 10 years you have no
idea who i am it's all about comedy with
you and moving up the ladder and pushing
people off
now is this are you getting out of an
existing house and uh i'm going from a
one-bedroom
apartment and i figured i'd finally go
out and buy a damn house
and not have to deal with you know some
jerk living above me or below me
all right you know yeah do my own little
thing get my little 12
gauge get a bunch of cans of tuna get
ready for the apocalypse that's what i
want to do
you just ignore them it's like three
days they flip out for three days
they try to bully you into an apartment
you can't ignore them when they're right
in the audience and you're playing to
them
you tell them to shut the [ __ ] up yeah
believe me
trump's winning new hampshire hillary's
winning uh
virginia really and there's a little kid
here
yeah somebody decided it was a good idea
somebody please take a photo of this
last supper
that's how you end it there we go right
there
oh my there we go where's the camera
right there you see that this is what
the
[ __ ] i do